it just listen it comes it comes down to
a million different things
i for me my intent
is legacy right so define legacy
i want everybody to remember that i
brought them value
awesome pleasure good to see you four or
five times
each time we publish book of garvey yes
we are talking
it's very amazing time for us that's
your book
yes how would you pronounce the title
that's my first question all the time
with the interview with the books
please share
crushing it to me it means that you're
living your life in a way that makes you
happy
right it's you're succeeding financially
emotionally mentally
and you're taking advantage of the
current state of the internet and
culture
in achieving that so it's not a zen
mindfulness meditation book it's
i believe that the internet is grossly
underrated
i believe human beings are grossly
underrated you put one and one together
if you execute and get educated
on what's actually happening in society
uh you really can start taking advantage
of it
you know i read this book five times and
it's awesome it's work it works the
number of business my life
but i think that many of people won't
believe in this book
during the reading because it sounds
like i know
strange things to do you know small
things on social media yes
can you talk us a bit more about this i
mean look i mean if if it was so easy
if everybody believed it everybody i
mean that's the truth you know like
look i mean go read the amazon reviews
for the first book crush it 2009.
everybody told me
the sbs the sbs snake oil salesman the
internet's not going to be real
people going to make money on youtube i
know
and now i'm laughing and they're not i
mean to me
i'm to be very honest and you probably
know this about me because
we've hung out a bunch i'm not
interested in convincing anybody in
poland or shmoland or america or
america or china or china that i'm right
i'm putting things on the record
and i'm letting the chips fall where
they may and i have a funny feeling that
i'll be on the right side of history and
if somebody is pessimistic
or lazy or struggling with something
inside that makes them say no not yes
i'm empathetic i don't think i'm special
i think that i'm sharing my points of
view just like you're allowed to share
your point of view and say no
not really this is all bad the
internet's bad this won't happen not in
my country
not in this cool you can be in the no
business
i'm going to be in the yes business
before this interview i asked my
community what would you like to ask
gary and yes most of them
asked the same questions as you answered
this book
yes and my reply was hey here's the book
with the answers
so my question for you is why people are
giving the same questions all the time
without looking themselves for the
answers they've heard the answers they
want to hear it one more time
people people want reinforcement to make
sure that that's the right
path or they the they've heard you but
they haven't
heard you i think a lot of you know it
maybe even for you
and you know you know and others even
people that have gone on to get a lot of
success from me
i get a lot of emails that are like hey
in the last year things have worked out
thank you
p.s i've been listening for three years
i don't know what it was about episode
219 or i don't know what it was about
this podcast or i don't know what
i mean plenty of people like i don't
know what it was about crushing it
that was different than askgaryvee that
was different jab jab that was different
and so it's been interesting and by the
way that's what drives me to continue to
say the same [ __ ] forever
you never know when it's going to be
this way with that lighting
with that adjective on that platform
right
yes i may say the same thing for a
decade listen i only have 25
30 points of view what i'm good at is
being relevant on the new and emerging
things whether it's voice or podcast or
video
look you know look what's going on here
right like it's the film over the film
or the filmers forgetting film
like it's very like for me these are the
things i predicted would happen
they seemed laughable years ago they are
not being laughed at by everybody as
much anymore
yeah probably at the beginning a lot of
people laugh from you like you're doing
dailyvee
most of them were saying like you're
like an [ __ ] you know that's right
looking stunning charlatan self-absorbed
thing and i had the same they told me
i'm narcissistic because i'm
coming to the street with the camera
pointing at me and they forget that i'm
putting content from my community to
make their life better
it just listen it comes it comes down to
a million different things
i for me my intent
is legacy right so define legacy
i want everybody to remember that i
brought them value
right period i want to be remembered
that i brought value i like it i like
the feeling it makes me feel good
sorry you know and so to me that's how i
think about it
and and so for me of course i'm doing
this
because that's what i want um to me it's
a
there's not a lot of things people want
in life you know there's money there's
admiration there's love
there's these things and all this stuff
is very basic to me comes simple
um i just don't care if people think i'm
the best or the worst
uh i'm in my own inside and so that's
why i will always
innovate because i don't fear you don't
fear
i don't fear so if dailyvee was a flop
if my sneakers were a flop what
nothing next project that's it
entrepreneur
this book is about patient yes can you
talk
us a little bit more about passion i
think patience is one of the great
secret weapons of my success
because you look like you're not patient
because you are in the long term but
short term you are very quick right
that's right
micro speed macro patients clouds and
dirt okay so what do you will advise
our polish viewers and readers about the
patients look
everybody's always trying to prove the
reason i'm patient is i'm not trying to
prove anything to anybody else but
myself
and i have my whole life to do that you
focus on your own [ __ ]
for my whole life to do that when you're
not patient you're worried about other
people
you want to be successful so your mom
was proven wrong
so your brother was proven wrong so you
proved some
you're doing it for somebody your lack
of pace you your lack of patience you
need more money you're not patient
because you need more money because you
have to buy bmw
so that you look successful to your
classmates not smart
not smart and so patience goes hand in
hand with being
inside your own self i'm i'm so thankful
that i only
guide within my own self otherwise i'd
be living my life in a very different
way
you know thank you economy
and the most people in poland after
reading this book are saying we know
this [ __ ]
it's okay there's nothing new in the
book but when i look at the
facebooks and youtubes there's there's
nothing there
you know what i mean of course i know
what you mean there are people who do
and then there are people who judge the
people that do yeah
i [ __ ] do which is which is why i
respect what people say
i don't want them to say that i respect
it but that's a much bigger indicator
on them than me one of the great things
i've been able to accomplish
in my own mind is this incredible place
where i'm at right now where i think i'm
just a mirror
i genuinely believe that people
when they consume me expose who they are
based on their reaction of me
do they leave like comments likes if
they think i'm
great they're in a positive accountable
place
if they think i'm [ __ ] they're in a
negative i want to blame somebody else
place and it's 100 and so
i just think i'm a mirror so i don't
take it personal
you know why i'm why i invoke reaction
because i suffocate people's [ __ ]
you know why people don't like me when
they don't like me they don't like
that i'm exposing them they like to hide
in the shadows
of their [ __ ] so if you guys want to
hide you can hide
facebook i'm just gonna have facebook
join you can hide all you want
but i'm gonna shed the [ __ ] life on
all these truths and you have to [ __ ]
deal with it one way or the other
because that's the [ __ ] game because
that's me bringing that's the most
valuable thing i can do by the way i
don't talk about that many things i
don't know about healthcare
i don't know about you know uh healthy
like there's you know
i'm not a know-it-all i'm a i know about
communication and human psychology and
buying and selling and business and
that's all not a lot i talk a lot i talk
with a lot of confidence because i talk
about the [ __ ] i know just like somebody
who's been teaching
swimming for 30 years can talk with
confidence too yeah
i've been doing business for [ __ ] 37
years for real
d's and f's for real because i've been
doing business for 37 years
and at this point i feel like i'm pretty
okay at it
and i'm willing to talk about it but
ultimately the reason people struggle
is because i don't let if i let you get
away with your [ __ ] i'd be like
everybody else who's selling them all
this [ __ ]
or you're saying are you cool no you're
not you're just lazy i will show you
that you're lazy
but you know what i would say you're
lazy for a reason
you know to me it's not like people are
lazy why are you lazy you're afraid of
something right or becoming right let's
go further
you grew up in let's talk about poland
you know i was born in belarus
i know that if you're born in poland the
history of that country
and the cadence of that individual and
the history of your grandparents
is a factor that is not a factor in
america but it's not a bad factor
i think adversity is an advantage
i think with the internet the people
born in more difficult situations
minorities tough countries actually
weirdly are set up for more success
so i look at your adversity
as a positive look the hero of my life
is my mother let me tell you about my
mother's life
she was born in the soviet union her
mother died when she was 5.
her father went to jail when she was 10
for 10 years
she had an older brother that she was
the older sister of
she married my dad who's a piece of work
the most difficult thing she she had a
child
at 20. she came to america with a
hundred bucks
she worked her [ __ ] face off every
day of her life and didn't have a
housekeeper
didn't take a vacation didn't go
anywhere she's the most positive
phenomenal person i know how the [ __ ] do
you think i'm going to cry for you
sure sure uh a lot of people
are talking about your jump jump like
hooks yeah but we focus
only on the right hooks yeah because the
right hooks are more fun
fun but most of them doesn't work right
because if you only throw right hooks
and i know that some people are giving a
lot of jobs
but they cannot right hook correct
they're waiting for
too long to ask for money two left two
right
you understand yes too idealistic too
selfish
you know i get it why do you think i
wrote a book called
jab jab jab right hook
that's the one i can't wait to
sell and throw right hooks for my
sneaker on july 16th
i can't wait to announce my secret wine
project in the fall
i can't wait i love selling me too i
just
love giving a lot too because it's
they you win three ways you give one
first of all here's a big part about
giving
i don't give away free content better
than anyone
because i expect people to buy my stuff
just give it because you want to give
correct would i like them to buy my
stuff of course
do i care if they do ultimately no
because
if i gave with expectation i would lose
so how would you put like a right hook
with this book for polish people
why they should buy it or not because
it's the greatest book ever written
poland
look it's not about why they should
here's what i think
i have a long track record of success
i think i've proven myself to a lot of
people that i'm in it for the right
reasons
and i don't think it's expensive to give
yourself a chance
but you can go i don't know watch the
videos for free listen to my podcast for
free i don't
you know listen i'd want to sell because
i appreciate your support i don't know
what you're on the hook for
but for me you know i don't want to
convince anybody to buy my stuff believe
in my stuff
i want to put out the best work i can
and then the market decides
warsaw the suburbs of warsaw and the
whole country decide if this is a
quality book for them
not me now look i think coming
in the fall is going to be a big deal
yes i don't know how many of these
[ __ ] things you got sitting around
but i have a funny feeling
i have a funny feeling you're gonna have
a lot less in october than you had in
september and so i'm excited
i will say this i cannot wait to come i
cannot wait to come
yeah um i'm bringing my dad who
doesn't go to anything fine so it's
gonna be great we'll do that and so
it'll be fun looking forward to it
thank you so much
[Music]